so the question today is what will be
the best diet for heart disease well
let's look at the things that can
actually cause the heart attack first of
all the coronary artery okay
it becomes clogged that is going to
obstruct blood flow to the heart muscle
and the heart muscle is gonna cramp and
your heart attack okay that would be one
okay so now let's talk about arrhythmias
you have a problem with the pacemaker
the rhythm of the heart is off and blood
can pool in different parts of the heart
and then it can develop a clot that clot
can then spread and clog an artery and
then you have a heart attack and then we
have the heart muscle itself let's say
you don't have a clogged artery but the
heart muscle itself just cramps to the
point where it's like a muscle cramp at
a new heart and you just basically die
of a heart attack so these are three
different mechanisms so let's reverse
engineer and look at the whole sequence
of events that happens that leads up to
some plaque or a clot so you don't just
end up with plaque you and you start
with inflammation okay so we have some
type of damage going on in the wall of
this coronary artery then the body
starts accumulating cholesterol protein
and calcium as a band-aid okay and so
you start developing clacking you can
also develop a clot and then when it
gets big enough it can either dislodge
or to stop the flow of the artery and
then we don't we no longer have oxygen
to the muscle tissue so what causes
inflammation or oxidation is high levels
of insulin usually okay and also low
nutrients it's a deadly combination
it's the nutrients specifically the
antioxidants that protect the tissue
against the oxidation or inflammation so
if you don't consume enough vegetables
to get your vitamin E or your vitamin C
or foods that have the beet complex then
you set yourself up for more damage in
the artery so we want to make sure that
your diet is not high in insulin okay
that's number one so of course we want
to get rid of the refined sugars and the
refined carbohydrates okay and how do we
get our antioxidants a lot of vegetables
will do it
okay so as far as the b-complex goes
because the B vitamins are on a lot of
foods but if you're consuming the
refined sugars and carbs that's going to
deplete the B vitamins think about when
you buy food with flour why do they
enrich it with B vitamins because when
they refine the flour they take out the
B vitamins and so when you consume that
flour without the B vitamins you
basically you create a deficiency of
more B vitamins because it takes those B
vitamins to metabolize that carbohydrate
okay the more carbohydrates you consume
the more B vitamins you need to
metabolize that consuming a lot of
refined grains and sugars depletes the B
vitamin complex all right now let's talk
about arrhythmias what nutrients control
the rhythm of the heart electrolytes
okay specifically potassium and
magnesium so what foods contain
potassium magnesium you guessed it
vegetables things like avocado leafy
green anything leafy green would have
magnesium in it and it just so happens
that both of these minerals are in
vegetables so if you're not consuming
any vegetables and you're consuming a
lot again refined carbohydrates you set
yourself up for depleting the
electrolytes and by the way when you
develop insulin resistance you you don't
absorb potassium or magnesium that well
so that can exaggerate the problem all
right
let's talk about the heart muscle itself
let's see you don't have a clogged
artery but you are very low in vitamin E
okay vitamin E has a very specific
purpose of increasing oxygen in the
heart muscle itself but if you're low in
vitamin E the heart has to work harder
and it will have a tendency to cramp up
and this could create angina and lead to
a heart attack a vitamin B deficiency
will also do it as well so you need
vitamin B and vitamin E for the heart
muscle and by the way by the mini as an
antioxidant protects the lining of the
artery okay so it's a very protective
nutrient and I mentioned this before the
way you become deficient in vitamin E
and in vitamin B
is consuming refined grades so it's not
always about just not consuming that
nutrient it could be that you're
consuming things that are depleting that
nutrient a lot of refined grains as in
white flour will deplete your vitamin E
and your vitamin B's okay and of course
you probably see this all the time that
you have to consume whole grains for a
healthy heart but in reality and most of
those whole grains come with a lot of
refined grain which they're saying
that's acceptable but any amount of
refined grains will deplete these
nutrients so and the problem with whole
grains is yes whole grain does consume a
lot of vitamin E and to be complex but
as soon as you grind the grain which is
the seed of grass it oxidizes and you
lose those nutrients so yes it's true
that whole grains do contain quite a bit
of vitamin E and we think about wheat
germ oil okay wheat germ oil it's low to
fight a mini and even to be complex but
when you grind the grain into flour
that's when you oxidize those nutrients
so when you buy this a whole grain bread
you're you're not realizing that they
made that bread weeks before and they I
don't know when they ground the flour it
probably wasn't fresh so they grind the
flour it sits in the shelf it oxidizes
and then they make the bread out of
whole grain well those vitamins already
destroyed unless you yourself are able
to grind your grain and then make your
bread but of course if you did that
you're going to be raising insulin
because of the nature of the
carbohydrates so yes you'll have the
vitamins in there that will protect you
to some degree but you also have the
spike in insulin so we're recommending
not doing grains on this eating plan you
know I just realized something this
really resembles the ketogenic plan
doesn't it it does
Wow what a coincidence so how if the
keto is what I'm gonna recommend for
supporting a healthy heart so if you
want more knowledge on how to create a
healthy body subscribe now and get daily
notifications daily notifications that
sounds weird well I'll just remind you
on a daily basis how about that